today I sat down with Luke's son Jack
who lost his beloved dad far too soon
isn't that I'm most proud of about my
dad always say he was a really good guy
the outreach and support I think it kind
of shows that he was loved by everybody
and um it's nice to see that from
everybody Jack actually worked as a
production assistant on the set and even
made a small appearance in the movie he
obviously saw the movie what did you
think was it hard to watch it was a
little bit but I was I was very proud of
it and um you know my dad was really
proud of it he was really excited about
it and so it was it was cool to see that
and I'm glad he got to do that the 22
year old even paid tribute to his dad by
scaling his Hollywood billboard what
inspired you to climb the Billboard you
know it kind of just had to do it that's
um I like climbing stuff and I saw it
there you know it'll only be there for
so long and I kind of wanted to
commemorate it being there forever in a
way Jack's
pinched it for climbing translates well
to his career as a professional wrestler
who goes by the alter ego jungleboy his
dad was his number one fan he was all
about it he yeah he was a big wrestling
fan
and he actually was the one who pushed
me to get trained and start wrestling in
the first place and it's a good thing he
did jungle boy is one of the stars that
the new wrestling league
all Olie rustling glow star awesome Kong
and nyla Rose are also headliners who
could kick each other's ass first
yeah
the experience
[Music]